so what is that process like to actually
deposit all this cash into the Federal
Reserve so you like leave the dispensary
with few millions of dollars worth of
cash correct because only these
dispensaries can only deal with cash
correct where do you physically have to
go to the or what do you have to
actually do to deposit this cash we
actually have a place we bring the money
it's actually processed it's actually in
a hardened facility and of course by the
time when they're counting this money we
have guys situated outside around the
facility again making sure nothing's
gonna go left and they start the process
of counting we have actually the cash
you've seen the big federal cash
counters that yeah that's what we use to
count the money okay obviously if you're
counting three or four million dollars
it takes you several hours yeah to get
that done then we have to bind that
money up process it into a plastic bag
see-through bag that has tamper
resistant so if you open it it tells you
through the tamper resistant tabs on the
side hey this has been opened up and
then once it's all packaged up and
stacked up real nice and neat you make
an appointment we have to be invited by
the Federal Reserve to actually deposit
this money there once they do it
background again it has to be fully
armored up truck we have a scheduled
appointment and from our scheduled
appointment we make the run now of
course the first time we did this we
pulled up outside the facility at three
million dollars we're kind of looking at
each other I was one of the one of the
other guys he was a retired cop and we
were kind of look at each other what's
going on he's like well I just want to
feel with his last two minutes of
freedom feels like I'm not sure what's
gonna happen or thing Federal Reserve
really so yeah we didn't know if they
were they could confiscate the truck
through forfeiture they could arrest us
they could take all the money there's a
several different things could happen
transpire at this particular time Wow
but it was uneventful we pulled in they
came out grabbed the cash counted it up
we were there for about 15 minutes and
then back on the road Wow
so turns into a better situation now
because obviously we're so used to doing
this we have the process down yeah we
have two facilities here in the state of
Florida two Federal Reserve here in
Florida one in Jacksonville and one in
Miami okay and we are in process now of
a few licensing that we're getting now
and probably in the next five months
will actually be transporting here in
Florida really it could be sooner could
be sooner but right now five months for
sure